كالعاده نجدد اللاعبين المسلمين مع الصيام
في رمضان حيث تداول مغردون مقطع فيديو
اثار جدلا واسعا لكريم بنزيما نجم فريق
ريال مدريد فقد اتهم بعض المغردين بنزيما
بالافطار خلال المباراه بعدما شاهدوه وهو
يشرب الماء ويتمض بها في المقابل تداول
ايضا رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو اظهر محمد صلاح وهو يرفض شرب الماء
اثناء الصيام
[موسيقى]
انتشر مقطع فيديو يظهر طفلا مصريا يطلب
دواء سعال لشقيقه الاصغر داخل صيدليه
ليستجيب زبون لرغبه الطفل ويشتري له
العلاج دون مقابل انتشار الفيديو دفع
وزاره التضامن الاجتماعي للتواصل مع
الصيدليه للتاكد من صحه الواقعه
الصغير
ده اخويا ده
[موسيقى]
والله ما انا عارف
احنا
هنا
[موسيقى]
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطعا طريفا لقطه
تفاجئ امام مسجد اثناء صلاه التراويح في
الجزائر نشاهد
[موسيقى]
لا
تخرج قل
[موسيقى]
نا تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو لطفل دخل على محل تجاري في
لبنان واقدم على سرقه بسكويت بسرعه خاطفه
وفر هاربا وسط ذهول من صاحبي المحل الذي
لم يلاحظ في البدايه بسبب صغري حجمه نتابع
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء